if you look at seattle the most radical
member of the city council
talks about getting visas now
jesus is the richest guy in the world so
he's an obvious target if you're a
socialist
but if you want to drive amazon
out of king county in seattle
you want to look at the this is what aoc
did when she blocked them
from going into her congressional
district and cost that part of new york
city
25 000 jobs and i don't think this i
mean
it will not surprise me one morning
bezos announced that amazon was moving
everything out of seattle and the cost
of the tax
both directly from amazon and indirectly
from all the workers who would then
leave
would be just staggering i mean it would
turn that would turn seattle into
detroit
so with all this in mind what do you
think the republicans
if anything could be doing better as
we're watching monuments being taken
down
and we're watching the mob just run
across cities
um you know i see the republicans are
sort of talking a tough game and trump's
talking a tough game but
but are they not doing something that
they actually should be doing because
this stuff isn't stopping
well i think there's a couple things
they should be doing first of all in the
long run
they should the republican national
committee to go into every major city
and create a jobs prosperity and safety
chapter and start to organize everybody
in the city
to win municipal elections and state
legislative elections
who are secondary people killed and then
they ought to plant a flag in every one
of these cities
and say we're going to reach out to
everybody who's sick and tired of having
no jobs
no schools that work and have and having
your relatives shot
and if that fits you let's sit down and
talk about you know how you can be a
candidate not not
we're not going to ask you to vote for
some traditional republican but we're
going to try to help you take back
your city second i think um
that the president has to look at the
example
that bobby kennedy set in the early 80s
and the early 60s
when young volunteers were being killed
in mississippi
during the civil rights movement and it
was clear
that the local sheriff who may have been
doing the killing and the state police
were not going to defend these people
and what they did is they said look
these are american citizens
and if you're not going to defend them
we are and they send in the fbi
and i think in a number of these places
that the young woman in indianapolis
the mother of a three-year-old who was
apparently shot over the weekend
for saying all lives matter um
you know there's a perfect example where
she lost all of her civil rights because
she's dead
uh i think they ought to say
you know we we are now going to create
strike forces
that are going to be prepared to go into
the south side of chicago prepared to go
into new york
any place which has is clearly spinning
out of control
if you if you won't protect your own
citizens we will
because they're american citizens and
and i think we have to be prepared to to
be much more aggressive
and much tougher about taking this on
then lastly we ought to create much
bigger uh
and more attractive opportunity zones
uh with benefits so great and with with
education opportunities so great
though we can actually begin to create
jobs in the inner city everywhere in the
country
are are you worried with all that in
mind that this this mix between
covid and riots and protests is going to
do sort of irreparable damage to small
business
across the board no matter what at this
point because if you weren't taken out
by kovid
and now again with the lockdowns if you
somehow survived
i have a friend who called me yesterday
who's a who's she's a masseuse she
usually goes to people's homes
she can't go to people's homes anymore
she got a little shop over the last
couple weeks just a little one-room
place
now they closed her down and she's
thinking to leave in california now and
she's not even sure what she's going to
do for a living anymore
that the average person you know the
corporations can basically deal with
these big blows but the average person
just
can't uh you know figure out a way to
live if every month something crazy is
going to happen
look i mean even big corporations brooks
brothers for example
which is a you know almost 200 year old
company
may have actually be 200 years old uh
that's filed for bankruptcy
right uh united airlines i mean even
really big places can get in trouble
but the points you make is important at
a couple of levels
i i work very closely uh with alfredo
ortiz and the job creators network and
uh they do terrific work helping small
businesses
and we have been much more proactive
than the europeans
at trying to help small businesses but i
think
one of the things you're going to see is
people are going to leave california
people are going to leave big cities
uh i mean i would not be at all
surprised to see new york lose virtually
everybody who has any resources
just because the taxes are too high the
streets are beginning to be unsafe again
you know people don't want to be in a
place that's out of control
if you look at seattle the most radical
member of the city council
talks about getting visas now
jesus is the richest guy in the world so
he's an obvious target if you're a
socialist
but if you want to drive amazon
out of king county and seattle
you want to look at this is what aoc did
when she blocked them
from going into her congressional
district and cost that part of new york
city
25 000 jobs and i don't think this
will not surprise me one morning visas
announced that amazon was moving
everything
out of seattle and the cost of the tax
both directly from amazon and indirectly
from all the workers who would then
leave
would be just staggering i mean it would
turn that would turn seattle into
detroit
all right so let's let's back up a
little bit because i know we can we can
sort of focus on this for
for the entire hour but i think your
career sort of well we could we could do
several hours on this easily
but i think your career and some of the
things that you have done
might help sort of light a way that we
can get out of some of this stuff so
when when you were speaker of the house
can you just talk a little bit
about how democrats and republicans
could or
could not work together and what you
think has happened that has led us to
just
i mean there's virtually none of it now
how you were able to
to make some of those fights and and
build some of those bridges or
have some of those bridges burned well i
would point out that in fact
when the crisis really hit this spring
uh
the house and senate did manage and i
give steve mnuchin
to the treasury some real credit but the
house and senate actually worked
together
and produced trillions of dollars in
spending
i mean that was they did it pretty fast
they did it pretty cleanly
there also has been a steady stream of
small bills that people can get together
and agree on
lamar alexander the senator from
tennessee is probably the
best example that he's a genius at
figuring out what they can do
rather than what what they can't do um
but
the key to what we did was very explicit
and people want to know about it
that can read a very simple small book
by tom evans
called the education of ronald reagan
reagan had after his movie career and
his tv career
he ended up spending eight years working
for general electric
and uh it was a really interesting story
because
he went around the country as a
spokesperson he talked gave about 375
speeches to factories
so he had a lot of practice talking to
blue-collar workers taking questions
being a celebrity which was great
preparation for running for governor
and in the process reagan was in a
period where he wouldn't fly an airplane
he did a
really bouncy flight in i think late 45
so he did not
fly an airplane again until 1965 and so
he went everywhere by train
and the guy he worked for was a very
conservative
uh intellectual the head of human human
relations and
union relations at general electric and
so this guy would give reagan
conservative economic votes
so here you have reagan driving you know
riding across the country to train
reading conservative economics preparing
his speeches
well reagan came up with a model which
he really got from from this particular
guy
which reagan summarized in
everyday language by saying my job is to
shine the light on the american people
so they will turn up the heat on
congress
but what that meant was you had to have
a program like three-year tax cuts
that was popular enough that the
american people would say to their
congressman
i really want you to pass this if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell